(crowd applauding)
- All right, let's finish up
with a story I hope will get you
into the early spirit of the season.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Tomorrow morning marks the
unofficial start of the holidays.
I'm talking about
the 97th Macy's Thanksgiving
Day Parade, people.
And they are delivering more
parade coverage than ever
with a three and a half hour event.
There are new floats and balloons,
performances from some of
Broadway's biggest shows,
and of course, old
Saint Nick will be there
to close out the festivities
like he always does.
Here with a sneak peek,
let's everybody say hello
to the executive producer
of the parade, Will Coss.
What's up Will?
(audience applauding)
- Hi, how's it going? How are you?
- I'm good, man.
Thank you for joining us.
How is planning going?
- Planning is great.
We've had a very busy last 12 months
building our brand new floats, balloons,
getting all the parade
elements ready to go,
finalizing our marching
bands, our performance groups.
It's set to be a pretty exciting show
on Thanksgiving morning.
- It must be crazy, it's a moving show.
I've been a part of it, but I
would never want to run that.
It's a lot of moving parts, man.
So volunteers are key for you, right?
- Volunteers are key.
The parade actually started 1924
with volunteers from
Macy's, and we've continued
that tradition over the last 97 parades.
So we'll have over
5,000 volunteers join us
and up to 8,000 people,
including all of our
performance groups, our bands.
So it's a big day, it's
a lot of folks coming.
A lot of folks excited to
bring the holiday tradition
back to the streets of New York City.
- Absolutely.
Well everybody, the 97th
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade
kicks off at 8:30 Eastern,
airing on NBC and streaming on Peacock.
Thank you so much, Will.
I'm liking your post right now, man.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Good luck.
- Happy Thanksgiving everyone.
(crowd continues cheering)
- All right, so usually at this point
we give our guest $1,000 courtesy of
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show."
But we are kicking off the
holiday season right here
by giving it to someone in the audience.
So,
(audience cheering)
pay attention to this monitor
and one of your faces is gonna show up.
(drum roll)
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
(crowd clapping)
(symbols crashing)
Yes! What's your name?
- Hi, my name is Logan Smith.
- Oh my gosh, nice to meet you.
What are you gonna do with the money?
- I have no idea.
(audience laughing)
- Well you gotta have a
little bit of fun with it.
People always say bills, that's nice.
That's nice, pay some bills.
But have some fun with it. Do you promise?
Just a little bit.
- Oh yeah,
I'm in my traveling era right now.
- Oh, yes.
(crowd clapping)
Go somewhere fantastic.
I love this for you. Enjoy it!
Thank you for coming to the show
and thank you to all our guests this hour,
Taika Waititi, John
O'Hurley, Jason Reynolds,
Natalie Pasquarella, John Gizza,
the high-tech High Choir, and our friends
at NBC4 New York-
(crowd drowns out monologue).
Have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.